I bet there's 100 answers
to this question.
But in the end,
the thing that matters most to me and
if you think about it,
I bet matters most to you,
which is your family and
your extended network of friends.
In the end, that is super important.
So while we get wrapped around the axle
of doing whatever we're doing,
it is really important to remember
that that's what matters most.
I'll say the other thing is perspective.
And this has been one of the delights of
being married to a neurosurgeon okay,
what we do in business is important.
It's incredibly important.
It's important to the employees of HP to
our bars, but no one gets hurt at HP.
No one dies.
And so remembering what's really
important is I think critical,
and I'll tell you a little story which
I've told on a number of occasions.
So one of my closest friends from Harvard
Business School, who was in my section,
had a great career in Los Angeles.
And has two children who are about
the same age as my children, and
her 24-year old went into the Green Berets
and was killed in Afghanistan in June.
So when things seem pretty tough,
remember your 24-year old did
not get killed in Afghanistan.
So I think you've just got to
remember what actually matters here.
And it's great to be wrapped up in work.
It's terrific but in the end that is
the perspective of what is really,
really important here honestly.
And I will say when I lost the governor's
race, it was hard to have that perspective
because it's what it could have,
should have.
If I'd done this, if I'd done that maybe
it would have turned out differently.
In the end, nothing really bad happened.
I lost the governor's race.
And my family was intact, my husband was-,
you just have to remember.
And then last but not least,
I would say, your reputation.
You have to be known as high integrity,
doing what you say saying what you mean
because everything can go away and
if you still have your integrity, intact.
And so often at eBay at HP I often ask
what is the right thing to do here?
And it's challenging because the right
thing to do is quite different in
different cultures.
And I always used to say to our teams, it
may be different in different countries.
But if your mother or your father or
someone you love your children were
reading the New York Times, and they knew
what you were doing, would they be proud?
Or if they were sitting in the eve of
the conference from watching the decision
making process would they be proud of you?
And that's the ultimate question
whether you're from Asia or
from Latin America, or for Europe.
Usually having that notion of what would
your parents think transverses all those
cultural norms about what's acceptable and
what's not.
So, I think those are the three
things that I'd point to right away.